[Musique]
bonjour alain-claude lagier bonjour
monsieur li moribond jour aux auditeurs
de martinique première alors vous êtes
le candidat du mpf le mouvement
populaire franciscain vous allez
conduire la liste une nouvelle dynamique
pour servir le françois vous avez 46 ans
vous étiez le directeur de cabinet du
maire du françois joseph nozaki ne se
représente pas et vous avait regagné
donc votre poste à la ctm vous êtes
aussi président de plusieurs
associations sein de la commune quelles
sont vos motivations pour quoi vous
allez à la bataille
aujourd'hui je suis candidat parce que
vous l'avez dit je suis impliqué dans la
vie de la ville du françois depuis mon
plus jeune âge je suis aussi celui qui a
été désigné à une large majorité par mon
mouvement le mouvement populaire
franciscain dans lequel ge devrait
pendant plusieurs années aussi je suis
le plus jeune des candidats
c'est à dire que je représente une
nouvelle génération
nous aurons une nouvelle dynamique pour
le françois et j'ai surtout
effectivement une vision pour ma commune
une vision faire de cette commune une
commune qui rayonne rayonne à la hauteur
des ambitions de la commune nous allons
parler tout à l'heure de votre programme
alors c'est une affaire de famille
offrant soir et au mpf puisque votre
père est l'actuel premier adjoint et que
vous êtes le neveu de maurice antiste
c'était pas une affaire de famille vous
savez les 200 militants du mpf qui m'ont
désigné ne l'ont pas fait parce que je
suis le fils ou le neveu de x ou y
ils l'ont fait parce qu'ils ont reconnu
en moins des qualités dès que je portais
surtout les valeurs du mouvement que
j'ai oeuvré dans cette commune que j'ai
un parcours vous l'avez dit associatif
très riche puisque intégré président de
plusieurs associations
ils l'ont fait pour cela et je ne
comprends pas ces arguments liés à la
famille parce que en fait la famille
c'est la chose la plus belle moi je suis
fier de ma famille je suis fier de mes
années nous avons parlé une famille
importante au françois on ne peut pas
faire sans les lavier non il n'y a pas
de famille et pourtant toupin pourtant
tout le monde
au même niveau dans notre conception en
tout cas et ses aînés dont vous parlez
on devrait pour le françois et je suis
fier de ce qu'ils ont fait je suis fier
d'avoir une famille qui a avoué kiki et
dynamique sur la ville il y en a
d'autres familles tir qui sont
dynamiques donc celle là et dynamique je
suis content fier de leur travail et
j'entends bien poursuivre le travail non
pas au nom de la famille mais au nom du
mouvement populaire france discret voire
même trop discret je suis plutôt dans
l'humilité
vous savez faire du bruit ce n'est pas
ce n'est pas dans madame est temps mes
méthodes vous avez des candidats vous
avez des gens qui font beaucoup de bruit
personnellement ce n'est pas la méthode
vous savez les meilleures choses sur
cette terre dans ma définition se font
dans le plus grand silence et donc il
faut parler lorsqu'il le faut mais il
faut savoir aussi ne pas forcément à
paris mais surtout à lyon
je suis plutôt un homme d'action plutôt
qu'un homme de parole vous savez on
parle on parle parfois et ça ne va pas
plus loin la tâche ne sera pas facile
quand on regarde les résultats de 2014
mathématiquement l'opposition a obtenu
plus de suffrages que le mpf qui à
benoït santista bénéficier de la
triangulaire notamment deuxième tour
ce la tâche ne sera pas facile mais la
division est bien marqué mais il y a
vous savez luzio de pouvoir qui jouent
tous avec maurice antiste et elle a le
plus de 20 ans et c'est vrai que ça joue
alors qu'il n'y a pas de difficulté à sa
vision du pouvoir ne touche pas
seulement pas ne touchent pas aussi le
mpf parce que ça fait 25 ans de mpf au
pouvoir ou françois oui c'est l'un des
principaux arguments des opposants mais
vous savez les franciscains ils vont
élire un maire est une équipe qu'ils
connaissent des gens qui ont oeuvré pour
la commune et ils vont il ya surtout
cette nouvelle dynamique que l'on
représentants parce que je suis entouré
de jeunes de moins jeunes des personnes
qui ont avoué des nouveaux visages aussi
je crois que c'est ce que les
franciscains demande au delà de partis
politiques précis le mpf avait joué et
les franciscains locaux connaissent et
nous verrons bien
au niveau élections en mars prochain
quels sont les grands axes de votre
programme
eh bien les grands axes ont déjà
déterminé je suis déjà dans les grands
axes parce que je suis au contact de
cette population
je suis au contact quotidien j'ai
amplifier le contact durant ces derniers
mois et nous allons continuer comme cela
nous allons dès que nous serons élus
mettre au travail
notre équipe notre équipe avec des
objectifs bien précis
nous allons aussi travailler activement
pour vivre l'oeuvre dans le cadre de la
mise hors d'eau du françois
parce que c'est quelque chose qui a
commencé mais qui mérite d'être
poursuivi l'éclairage du stade i pour
bientôt
l'éclairage du stade est en cours vous
avez vu si vous tracez devait arriver du
courant janvier s'ils nous fera sur
électorale vous savez si vous êtes
habitué des dossiers administratifs les
dossiers prennent énormément de temps et
ce dossier aboutit aujourd'hui parce que
simplement ben le temps est arrivé
merci avec l'au-delà j merci
[Musique]